to find a location near you
again I'm going to say one more time go
to
vaccines.gov to find a a place where you
can get the shot near you
we're working with doctors Community
groups Faith leaders and companies
leaders of some of our nation's largest
largest pharmaceutical change I said are
standing behind me
they're all stepping up to help more
people get vaccinated
some are offering coupons when people
get their updated covet shots
get the shot five ten twenty dollars off
the your drugstore grocery purchase next
or grocery purchase next time at the
same time you get the shot some are
making it easier just to walk in and get
your vaccine right away including on
nights and weekends and others from the
private sector are stepping up to as
well including delivering coveted
treatments right to people's homes for
free now
what do you do if you think you have
covert well please get tested so you can
be treated
we mailed out hundreds of millions of
free test kits earlier this year
we had to pause the program because
unfortunately some of our friends in
Congress fail to continue to fund the
covert response
but if you have already used up these
free tests that's okay we have required
health insurance comp we've required
health insurance companies to cover free
at-home tests eight tests per person per
month
folks on Medicare and Medicaid can get
free at home tests as well
and we have made free testing widely
available in communities
and then
if you test positive for Cova get
treated we have amazing treatments
available now they can help stop covered
infections from turning into serious
illness
we are the only large country in the
world
that made factslovid pack paclovit
widely available for free you can get it
prescribed by your doctor or at
thousands of tests or tested tree sites
or even from your local pharmacist
pick it up for free at your farm it's a
pill it's a pill
it's easy
Pax lovid can save your life it's worth
it and here's the bottom line
virtually every covert death in America
is preventable virtually everyone almost
everyone who will die from Cova this
year will not be up to date on their
shots or they will not have taken Pax
lovid when they got sick
we've made the vaccines free and
available we've made the tests free and
available
we've made Pax lovid free and available
please use them use them and encourage
your friends and loved ones and
neighbors to use them as well it can
save a life
to employers help your employees get
vaccinated set up a vaccine clinic in
your in your building
give people time off to get it if it's
not if necessary
share good clear information just like
you do for the flu shots
school and college leaders
help your communities get vaccinated
this fall host on-site clinics before
Thanksgiving
and to our friends in Congress it's time
to step up with much needed covert
funding
help us stay ahead of the virus
keep our communities going strong with
free vaccines free tests and widely
available treatments as we've done so
far
some of our friends in Congress say we
don't need covet funding or they say
they're really no reason that the
government should be paying for it
I strongly disagree
strongly disagree this is a global
Health Emergency
if you really want to put cover behind
us we have to keep up the fight together
we can't leave people to face it alone
some members of Congress say they don't
want to move Beyond covet but they don't
want to spend the money to do it
we can't help both ways
the funding we seek is critical to
continue the work to develop and
purchase the most effective treatments
and vaccines against covet it's
important it's important
now I want to speak directly to those
with special conditions
new variants may make some existing
protections ineffective for the
immunocompromised
sadly this means you may be at a special
risk this winter
so I urge you I urge you to consult your
doctor on the right steps to protect
yourself
take extra precautions
I also want to say this
as we enter this new moment in the
battle against covet let's use it to
start fresh as a country
to put all the old battles over covet
behind us
to put all the partisan politics aside
we've already lost over one million
Americans to covet over 1 million
Americans to covet
and we can do so much now to reduce the
number of people who die from this
terrible disease
we have the tools
we have the vaccines
we have the treatments
none of this is about politics
it's about your health
the health of your loved ones
what close is this
over the past 20 months
my Administration has left no stone
unturned
to make life-saving tools widely
available and easily accessible
now coveted cases are down by more than
80 percent from when I took office
covered deaths are down nearly 90
percent
and now we're in the longest stress
stretch since the virus emerged when our
hospitals are not overrun with severely
ill covered patients
that didn't just happen
it took a combination of incredibly
effective vaccines tests and treatments
to get us there
one of the biggest Public Health efforts
ever undertaken in this country
together we did it
let's keep doing it let's keep going
this fall get your coveted shot and get
your flu shot it's simple it's easy
for most Americans it's one of the
coveted shots per year one once a year
is going to be required and it's most
important thing you can do
so thank you and now I'll show you uh
just how easy is to get that shot
you're not giving me a shot
all right
what am I doing my left arm
all right
okay
Mr President it's close to a national
emergency
it's a necessity to deal with making
sure it doesn't come on
oil urging you guys have to use desserts
certainly I think it was a mistake from
New York to work
say again
no I don't think I that's a local
judgment
thank you
[Music]
what is
[Applause]
your president we're in constant contact
with Russian authorities to get Brittany
and others out and so far we're not
familiar with much uh
do you believe
the dirty bomb allegations from Russia
as it relates to Ukraine do you believe
that this is the beginning of a false
flag operation is Russia preparing to
deploy a dirty bomb itself or a nuclear
weapons
I uh
I spent a lot of time
today talking about that uh
let me just say
Russia would be making an incredibly
serious mistake
if we're to use a tactical nuclear
weapon
I'm not
guaranteeing you that it's a false flag
operation yet don't know
but it would be a serious serious
mistake
much we appreciate it thank you
thank you
[Music]